these elections we know that due to the
pandemic people are not going to be able to
vote and as they typically do this
is this year what is going to happen is that
the people who are registered to vote are
going to receive their bulletin in the mail
and  What they have to do is fill out their
bulletin, vote there, and then they have to sign it and
send it back to the elections department,
although it's a little different than
how we typically do it, this process
is also easy, it's also convenient,
and it's also going to make sure that we
stay
protected during this pandemic
for people who want their newsletter in
Spanish what they can do is visit
the secretary of
state's website and update their
voter registration to say what they want
is their material in Spanish
if they previously registered for
vote they wrote down there that the wind their
material in Spanish
so the material is going to arrive
in Spanish at their house then it is
simply exist  e
and they need to update their
voter registration we are not aware that there may
be confusion and a little
concern with voting by mail
because it is the first time that we are going to
do it but this process is
in fact very safe and it is very
convenient it is a process that  a lot of
people have been using it for many
years people who are in the
armed forces typically use the post office to be
able to vote and we also know that the
post office is not one of the agencies that
we have a lot of trust there they have
our checks ours arrive they reach us
our medicine by mail
different things then there is no more there is
no reason why
and not to have confidence in our mail
so even if we make sure that
we sign it where the bulletin has to be signed
and send it back with that
we are going to be sure that it
counts  your ticket and if I lost it the
people who are a little bit nervous
and they don't know and they're a little bit nervous
and they want to make sure that their b  bulletin
reaches the department of elections what
you can also do is follow your
bulletin by
visiting the page of the secretaries
of the secretary of state
and there you can follow your bulletin and where
all the people who are going to
vote by mail are currently, you don't have to
worry  for paying nothing when
your newsletter arrives at the ncaa in the
mail at home and you see it coming with the
stamps so that you simply
have your newsletter, vote for the people
you want to vote for and from there you put the
stamp on it and send it back  That is
not going to be done or at a cost to you
for us in the action plan it is very
important that we
as immigrants go out to vote
for my person who has a
lot of family who are also
undocumented who are immigrants
we know the importance of our
people that our communities come out
to vote, so for us it is very
important to make sure that these
communities have the information
and are  prepared to be able to vote in
these elections, so our
focus is on the Afro-
American community, the indigenous community, the community that loves
immigrants, and also the community that
is sometimes considered poor, because
we know that our
communities are the ones that are always
impacted when the government does not
what we our communities
need then the elections is an
opportunity to go out and vote for the
people who are actually going to be the
change that we need in
our communities
that foresees stoking the corporations or
the people who already make too much
money then for us  the
elections is very important to
make sure that those people who
need the change ams bleed to vote
and use their voting power the most
important date they have to remember is
october 15th because if they are not
registered as active voters
then it is gone  to be very difficult for
them to receive your newsletter in  the
mail then they would have to go vote
in person after october 15th in
the state of nevada they can register
to vote until election day
then after october 15th they
can still vote take action they can
still register to vote and go out to
vote  but we do recommend that you
review and update your
voter registration to make sure that
your bulletin arrives in the mail, you can
do it quickly and easily and do not have to
put yourself at risk of the committee's in the
pandemic that we are in right now but
equal risk to make sure that
our communities
don't contract the virus and stay
healthy at home but I want to
urge the community to go out and vote
to tell their families their
relatives and their friends to also
go out and vote because our  community
needs your vote and needs your voice in
this election